PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Today, we're talking
about optimizing with
recommenders, Google Cloud
certifications, and
data center security.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia,
and welcome to "This Week
in Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
With recommenders, our goal
is to suggest quick, easy ways
to optimize your cloud
for price, performance,
and security.
Several recommenders are
already available today,
including Virtual Machine
Recommender, Viral Insights,
and IAM Recommender.
And now we're releasing the
beta of our new Recommendations
Hub, which highlights proactive
recommendations in one place
for you to view and act on.
Two years ago, we
created a gaming solution
to bring real world games
to life with the Google Maps
Platform.
While the initial release was
with a limited group of game
studios, we plan to expand
to independent game studios
and developers.
So we focused on building a
scalable infrastructure that
would support all developers.
And now we're releasing our
Google Maps Platform gaming
solution to all mobile
game developers,
to create engaging,
immersive, real world games.
Check out the blog to learn
more and try it for yourself.
Our Google Cloud training allows
you to build cloud skills,
while our certifications help
organizations find expert cloud
talent.
We are continually working to
improve our learning paths,
and now we're announcing
three new initiatives.
We are introducing Google
Cloud Skill Badges,
so you can show off
your demonstrated skills
and expertise.
We're offering six-week programs
to help experienced cloud
professionals prepare for
the certification exams.
And since our exam centers
are currently closed,
we have created
online-proctored testing
for three of the
certification exams.
At Google Cloud, we tend to
obsess about data security.
And we offer plenty of
products and services
to help our customers
secure their data.
But we're just as
focused when it
comes to physical security
of our data centers.
After a series of
checks and approvals,
my teammate Stephanie
Wong was given permission
to visit an actual data center
and create a video showcasing
how safe and secure
your data really is.
In this video, Stephanie will
show off the six security
layers, from the secure
perimeter to the data center
floor, that fewer than
1% of Googlers ever see.
It's a pretty cool
behind-the-scenes look,
so be sure to check it out.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.